welcome to this
round table discussion on the teaching
archive
i'm alice kaplan i'm the director of the
whitney humanities center and i will be
moderating today
allow me to briefly introduce our
authors and participants
first rachel sagner burma teaches
english literature at swarthmore college
where she co-directs the idol foundation
a center supporting interdisciplinary
liberal arts education
her work focuses on 18th and 19th
century literature and print culture
the history of the novel 20th century
anglo-american literary criticism and
the history of higher education
she's working on a book on the social
literary critical origins of narrative
omniscience
and she has another book project on how
victorian novelists did their research
laura heffernan teaches english
literature at the university of north
florida
and her focus is 19th and 20th century
literature and culture
histories of reading and histories of
literary criticism
she teaches courses on the history of
the novel modernist literature
digital methods and literary study and
later periods of british literature
she's currently serving as director of
unf's
digital humanities institute together
they have published the teaching
archive a groundbreaking approach to
literary history
that takes us inside the classrooms of
major literary critics
through their class notes and archives
and what better time than now
after this year of exile from our own
classrooms
to acknowledge the classroom experience
as a prime
incubator of critical thought eye
opening
paradigm shifting restorative humbling
all these words came to mind as i was
reading the teaching archive
we are note that we are putting a link
to the book with the university of
chicago press discount on the chat
feature
rachel sagner burma and laura heffernan
will be joined today by caleb
smith professor of english and american
studies at yale university
who also teaches american literature at
mcdougall walker correctional
institution
through the yale prison education
initiative
caleb smith's work explores the
contradictions in american history
between liberty and enslavement
democracy and domination secularism and
fanaticism
and you can read a chapter from his
forthcoming book disciplines of inte
of attention in a secular age in
critical inquiry
now i'd like to turn the floor to rachel
and laura who will give an overview of
the teaching archive
caleb smith will respond and then we
will open the floor to questions
so please post your questions at any
time during the presentations
in the q a and don't hesitate to use the
chat
for your expressions of interest and
enthusiasm
and for relevant bibliography rachel and
laura
alice thank you so much for that lovely
introduction
um can you see me okay great
um and thanks to diane and sarah and the
rest of the whitney humanities staff
also thanks also to caleb for joining us
today we're really looking forward
to our conversation with you um
so the teaching archive recovers the
everyday teaching of literary scholars
over the course of the 20th century
in order to write a new history for the
discipline of english studies
and this book really began with our
dissatisfaction with existing approaches
to disciplinary history
so far and with the ways in which
disciplinary practice gets represented
in contemporary
battles over reading methods uh existing
disciplinary histories tend to take a
selective and we think
kind of distant view of our profession
we're thinking here of gerald graf's
professing literature or john guillory's
cultural capital
to the extent that these disciplinary
histories perform research
on our disciplines history their
research tends to survey the
discipline's most self-conscious moments
rather than its kind of practical
everyday ones
traditional disciplinary history of
english studies tends to turn to
methodological manifestos and
professional addresses
mission statements and public feuds um
and it tends to produce a sense of our
past that emphasizes innovation and
originality and
rupture rather than the everyday
continuities
that we think are more familiar to
everyday practice
so for us and we think for many others
this produces a kind of
alienating and not so useful account of
our profession
um participat method wars are not a good
representation of the everyday practices
of the discipline and the day-to-day
work of it the longer continuities
that extend across our training and knit
us together
um disciplinary histories also we know
this
tended to ignore are really part of our
really major part of our professional
lives our classroom teaching
there's been a tendency just a sort of
default tendency to assume
that english professors practice some
form of close reading in the classroom
no matter what they were actually doing
in their research and there's recurring
reference to just a small
set of pedagogical theoretical texts
like practical criticism or the well
wrought urn
and textbooks like understanding poetry
brooks and warren tend to stand
in for the real history of teaching
so we decided what we wanted to do was
take a closer look at what and how
professors have taught
by seeking out their teaching papers and
so what we did to do that do that was
come here to yale first
to the beineckey um to look at cleon
brooks's teaching papers we were curious
to know whether and how brooks's
classroom teaching matched his account
in the well-wrought urn
of how and why an english professor
should cultivate students appreciation
for aesthetic form
and the really unique thing that we
never found again that we found in
brooks's tapers was a transcription of
his modern poetry class from the early
1960s
he had contracted with i think random
house to write a book based on
those lectures and so it employed a
stenographer to
transcribe every single thing the back
and forth between himself and the
students
even like the initial chat at the
beginning of the class period
and we never got to see that again
after working on brooks though we
decided that we wanted to move outwards
and look at other kinds of institutions
um we were really curious to know
what teaching looked like at
institutions
at the kinds of institutions in which
most people who go to college to go to
college i.e
not yale even though most disciplinary
histories tend to center
on elite institutions like yale um and
laura's gonna tell you a little bit
about the kinds of places the kind of
different kinds of institutions
where we went to look at classrooms um
yes so we thank you
so after we looked at
brooks's papers at yale we went to go
look at
jay saunders reading jay saunders
readings archive
his teaching papers from hampton
university
we looked at caroline spurgeon's
teaching papers at bedford women's
college
from the early 20th century we looked at
t.s eliot's papers from the workers
educational association tutorial
he taught which we'll talk about in a
minute we looked at ia richards's
teaching papers at cambridge
and eth records teaching papers at the
university of chicago
we also looked at simon j ortiz and what
he had taught at marin college
in northern california and the
university of new mexico
and dna college and we looked at
josephine miles
her teaching at berkeley we looked at
josefina nigley teaching drama at
western carolina
college in the 1950s
we actually looked at many more archives
than we ended up including in the book
and
as we'll describe today each of the
places that we went
uh sort of required us to develop
a new approach to our research and each
place really
taught us something different so um
we'll start talking today the first
example we will take you through
is t.s eliot's modern english literature
tutorial
which he taught here um at southall
grammar school
just outside of london from 1916
through 1919 so during world war one
um elliot taught a couple of extension
courses in these years
but he the this course was a course
taught through the university of london
but in partnership with the workers
educational association
and so it was a three-year tutorial
course
and one of the things we had to do was
go look at a bunch of different
wea tutorial syllabi to kind of
understand
the institutional values
of these particular extension courses
so wea syllabi reflected
the the fact that these tutorials were
meant to be
an exercise in kind of deep equality
teachers were
fellow students students were fellow
teachers
and um you know they agreed to study
together for three years
it was essentially a community building
exercise so communities decided
what courses they wanted to take and
then once they had embarked on a course
with a tutor
of their choosing they would work
together to revise
the course list in in years two and
three
of the syllabus um by and large these
students kind of rejected
the university's schemes to
kind of elevate the best among them to a
place in the university
for them the point was really to extend
study outside of the seminar itself
so wea students often re-taught their
classes to other community members they
have held study groups including family
members
and the idea was that study would create
more study rather than individual
achievement or accreditation
and so when we looked at elliot's
syllabi it was really clear to us that
he
learned how to adjust his pedagogy
to the wea he made significant changes
between his first and his second year
and then his second in his third year he
responded to
what the students wanted to learn and he
slowed down
this is probably familiar to those of
you who hear our teachers he became much
less ambitious in what he thought he
could cover
in the second and third years and most
notably he moved from a syllabus
that was organized around the individual
author
to a syllabus that was deeply
interconnected and that brought back to
life the material working world of
elizabethan writers
so this had a practical purpose for him
it helps students engage in individual
study to follow up their particular
interests
and to write seminar papers that would
then continue to be useful and to
connect back up with class discussion
in later weeks but it also
sort of allowed the class to reimagine
these writers as working
as workers as working writers you can
see in the elizabethan
literature syllabus i have up here he's
teaching not an author based syllabus
but he's teaching popular festival and
religious right in week one
renaissance humanism the elizabethan
stage
students are learning a lot about the
context in which these writers
were working
and once you see how elliott adapted his
teaching to the values of the wea to the
workers education association you can
also see really dramatically
how his classroom teaching shaped his
public writing so while elliott was
teaching his elizabethan literature
seminar he was also writing his famous
book of essays the sacred wood
which if you don't know it is a book
really often credited with changing
literary tastes in the anglophone world
of letters
into something more spare and formal and
elite saying goodbye to tennyson and
hello to dryden and dunn
the sacred wood includes essays on
figures like marlowe and massenger and
johnson
whose plays elliot had read with his
students in his seminar
but the connections are even much deeper
than that because what you really
see in the idea of literary tradition
that elliot famously talks about in
sacred wood is
how the wea impacted elliott's sense of
that tradition of literary value
you really see in the sacred wood a
sense of writing
as important not for its singularity and
originality but for the extent to which
it makes further writing possible
so while most readings of the sacred
wood focus on literary tradition
as elite and elliot's view of literary
tradition as a leading specialist once
you see elliot's classroom
you really realize that that view of
literary tradition is much more about
work a day writing and the possibilities
of collective writing
and then this was an insight that we
began to see everywhere we looked after
we realized this about elliot's
classroom
sort of being inside encoded inside the
sacred
wood we realize that classrooms live
inside and have strongly shaped many
many
of the major works of criticism that we
read and teach
so we realized for example that edmund
wilson's historical interpretation of
literature essay grew out of his
varieties of 19th century criticism
course that he taught at chicago in 1939
we came to see that carolyn spurgeon's
still cited work shakespeare's imagery
and what it tells us
that she published in the 1930s grew out
of the art of reading course that she
taught at bedford college for women
in the 19 teens and we saw how simon
ortiz had worked out the ideas for his
important essay towards the national
indian literature
while he was revising his native
american lit course between 1976 and
1979
for students at marin college
so we're just uh we're going to give
another example
of how this happens so the second
example this is
the course book list for josephine miles
is english 1a
course miles was a poet and a professor
she was the first woman
tenured in the english department at
berkeley and
she taught a bunch of different courses
in the department she taught a very
popular
verse composition course she taught
upper level seminars and graduate
seminars on the lyric
and on 17th century poetry and research
methods
but she most commonly taught english 1a
which is essentially the first year
writing course at berkeley and she
taught it for over three decades
you can see here the you well you maybe
can't quite see but the book list that
she's jotted down for her students
included includes a style guide a
dictionary
also virginia woolf's mrs dalloway a
modern classic of their choosing
so they can choose mon or proust or
joyce or shaw or o'neill
a modern best seller she says c scrap
lists
story magazine poetry magazine harper's
the southern review the new yorker
the new republic and a specialty
magazine
miles is every archive we went to people
keep their teaching notes very
differently
miles kept tons of teaching notes on
these tiny pieces of notebook paper
in tinyscript and she did keep notes for
every semester of english 1a that she
taught
and the notes really testified of the
fact that it was a very
workshop style course she said in fact
to the students at the beginning of
the fall 1940 course she described it as
a lab
or machine tool course where the prof
doesn't tell
and just watches practice and
she would often begin this course with
what she called the corner
essay she would send students out to a
street corner usually the corner of
oxford university in berkeley
and she'd ask them to stand there for an
hour and then write an essay about it
and quite often the students would give
her a first draft back that was simply a
chronological report of everything
they'd seen while they were standing on
the street corner
and she would work with them to revise
the essays so that the essays would have
perspective
so that they would order a little bit
more the sense data that they had
acquired
give a little bit more of a narrative or
a story give meaning to what they'd seen
and that kind of work of taking
perspective was something that miles
thought about as beginning
at the level of the sentence so the
writer of a sentence
orders the elements in the sentence
through syntax
through subordinating clauses connecting
and prepositions
and so miles had students work on
sentences over and over
in english 1a she had them write 50 word
sentences together
she had them choose a sentence from a
reading and analyze its function and its
transition
she had them write a sentence on that
encapsulated a belief
that they held and she you know they
worked every single day essentially on
sentences
and this interest in language at the
level of the sentence went alongside the
quantitative work miles was doing
from the 1940s forward she was working
with a big corpus of english poetry to
count the vocabulary of each era
trying to characterize the vocabulary
that poets had to work with
as sort of to hand in each era as
phrasal or clausal
is focused either on adjectives
basically are on nouns
if we could have table a from continuity
you can see some of her results there
up um to the left so we realized while
doing this work also that miles is one
of the foundational figures in distant
reading and digital humanities in
addition to the hand-counted data
the dozens of monographs she published
which she helped her graduate students
helped her with quite a lot
in the 1940s she also created a
computerized concordance to the complete
works of john dryden
she um inherited this concordance dryden
project from
a senior colleague and ended up
collaborating with her graduate students
and with the women in the
electrical engineering department at
berkeley that ran the ibm machines
so uh roberto abusa father abusa is off
really still to this day
thought of as the father of digital
humanities and a computationally
assisted literary study
um but miles made her concordance of
dryden far
before he made his and really she is
really
we think one of the founders of distant
reading in a way that
that isn't and that's a kind of dramatic
example of how looking at
teaching archives can totally change
like we think about the history of our
discipline
but in general looking at teaching
archives gives us a really new view of a
few different things which we're just
going to chat about
very briefly before we turn to our
conversation with caleb and with the
rest of you
um across all the archives and the
classrooms we looked at we see a really
different history of method
broadly we see not a kind of
contrapuntal set of
arguments played out in publications but
we see especially a longer and more
nuanced kind of historicism
is just an example but we also find a
really different view of who has made
our discipline because once you realize
that teachers have made
teachers of literature have made our
discipline um
you have a lot more possibilities for
thinking
about its fashioning and its shaping
um looking at these teaching archives
also has given us a really different
view of
what has been taught in the classroom so
yes
canonical texts in all of these archives
but also a long long tail of less
canonical texts and in fact
totally unliterary text maybe as much as
half of what's taught in classrooms we
think is not canonical at all so you
still get shakespeare you still get
mrs dalloway but you also have all these
other things
um and then the last thing we wanted to
touch on
uh the other thing that we saw
throughout these archives is how closely
teaching and research and publication
are
intertwined in a way that we think they
still are for most
practitioners today despite the fact
that the modern research university has
really like done its very best
to pull them apart um so the very idea
that we can have
teaching faculty or adjuncts like people
who are economic workers who are not
imagined as doing research at all as
part of their job
is a huge part of this obviously as our
10-year processes and all kinds of other
mechanisms but we think it's a real
testament to the strength of the actual
long history
of teaching and research being
intertwined that so many of us continue
to experience them as connected
despite all these administrative
mechanisms that that make us pull them
apart laura is there anything else you
want to say
briefly okay um so
caleb and alice i think you're gonna
oh we're sorry we're gonna turn over to
caleb who's gonna speak a little and
then we're gonna
talk with caleb
thanks rachel and laura for that
presentation and for your fantastic book
thank you to
alice and whitney humanity center
organizers
and staff for uh inviting me to be
a part of this event i um
have the highest respect for the rigor
and intelligence
and thoughtfulness of this book the
teaching archive
and i'm so excited to be um here to have
a chance to talk about it with you
i just wanted to say a little bit about
the shape of the book and
what it means to me i'll say a little
bit about my own teaching
i'll mention one of our own some
teaching archives that we
have here at yale and then um i'll ask a
few questions about what i take to be
some of the
kind of implications of the book or the
bigger arguments that you've
um offered to us so this
book brings two
teachers of english teachers of
literature students of english
literature
some very basic questions and very
serious questions
what is this discipline of literary
studies
what are its origins how has it changed
over the past
half century or century who participates
in it
who shapes its practices it's
self-understanding
what are its characteristic theories
methods arguments
materials as uh
laura and rachel have mentioned a number
of histories of the discipline have been
written
and many of them tend to follow
a more or less by now familiar
kind of arc they are histories of
prevailing ideas or
in other words histories of what english
professors have
said about what they're doing in their
work and by their work they normally
mean their
published scholarship i think it's
probably true that if you
ask a number of english professors about
their work they'll take you to be asking
about
their writing or about their scholarship
whereas if you ask them about their job
they might take you to be
asking about their teaching and their
service
so those histories of the discipline
perhaps tend to focus on
influential books and articles in which
literary critics explicitly reflect on
their own practices and the
kind of debates of their time and this
produces an account of the history of
the discipline that sort of
organized around some strong
disagreements between
camps philologists versus atheists
historicists versus formalists
multiculturalists versus the defenders
of a canon those are some of the
familiar kind of patterns that emerge
and then there's a kind of story about a
big
change that happens sometime around or
after 1968
when the discipline moves from the era
of the old new critics
to a more diversified and
interdisciplinary enterprise that's
drawing from traditions in
critical theory cultural studies area
studies
ethnic studies and other fields
and here's where laura and rachel in the
teaching archive make their big
intervention they ask us to look
not at what literary critics have said
or explicitly
how they've explicitly described their
project but instead
look at the materials that they have
produced
as teachers the true history of english
literary study
resides in classrooms they write in one
of their most political
moments maybe in the introduction and
maybe even more politically
disciplinary historians of english have
by and large
declined to research in their field
in other words we won't really know the
history of our discipline until
we study the history of its teaching in
classrooms
so the classroom as a space of
experimentation
as a space of research and creative work
not
only the transmission of knowledge from
the teacher to the student
and here they argue against the kind of
separation of teaching and research
in how the discipline understands its
own history
and in how our work as well is measured
and assessed
whether by each other's by each other or
by the universities or perhaps
by the public i wanted to touch on three
kind of consequences
of this uh methodological reorientation
of the history of our discipline
one what they show us is that in
practice literary studies draws from
many methods mixing formal analysis with
historical contextualization
mixing close reading with ideology
critique
mixing thematic questions and uh
complicated
um sort of computational techniques
somewhat
promiscuously and as rachel and laura
mentioned in their
introductory remarks we would probably
find this to be true if we were just
reading through the kind of practical
criticism of any particular period
and we certainly find it in the
classrooms but we find it less
in kind of method wars situations where
people feel
compelled to align themselves with one
method or with one
argument or with one concept against
some uh
some opponent in a debate and so
uh the so laura and rachel are kind of
teaching us how
not to separate those various the kind
of eclecticism of the discipline
out into those mutually antagonistic
camps
second there's a kind of historiographic
argument
about when and how the era of close
reading or the era of the new critics
gave way
to some time of pluralism in the methods
and objects of literary study
and there what the teaching archive is
showing us is that it's not really
right to say that there's a kind of post
1968 diversification
it's particularly not a kind of set of
arguments within elite institutions that
then
radiates out and transforms the
curricula at other institutions
across the country or around the world
but instead that
there were many different kinds of
practices going on at many different
kinds of institutions all along that
that kind of eclecticism and
diversity of theories and methods is
there if you go and look for it in
different kinds of classrooms
finally maybe most controversially
there's a set of kind of
ethical and political arguments about
what happens when we value teaching
when we value what happens in the
classroom and how that might
uh help us to defend our discipline in a
time of crisis how it might help us to
see a kind of common cause across uh
methodological differences
and the sort of difference that this new
history might make
in this time of crisis in our discipline
where the question some people might be
asking is less
what is literary studies and more what
was
literary studies
i found this book to be an illumination
and to resonate with my own experience
in teaching both in yale university
classrooms
and in prison classrooms two kinds of
institutions that are sort of at the
margins of the big central picture that
laura and rachel are
drawing drawing for us in the teaching
archive
and in those uh classrooms i've found
especially in teaching across
the two of them i found how teaching
with different groups of students even
with the same more or less the same
syllabus
uh has really caused me to reorient my
sense
of what counts as remedial in one
situation and what feels advanced in
another situation
or what feels radical in one situation
versus feeling
uh conservative or even reactionary in
another situation and so
um it does seem right to say that the
practical experience of teaching and
working with students in our discipline
really kind of reorients and
destabilizes some of the
conventional and rigid oppositions that
we make
uh when we argue perhaps badly about
what it is that we're doing
i wanted to show a couple of images
these are from uh
not from my own teaching archive but
they are archival images
uh held here at yale on the bionic key
this is james weldon johnson
in his classroom at fisk university
around 1933
i show it partly because we're all
nostalgic
and miss being in classrooms with each
other miss
working with each other but also because
as soon as you see this image
you see how it raises such complicated
questions about
elitism and anti-elitism about hierarchy
and equality about democratization and
integration
uh in the context of fisk university in
the 1930s
my second image is from johnson's own
teaching notes and this is a list of
paper titles
of uh that of papers that his students
wrote for the course
i i brought it to you partly because of
the little crossout that you'll see
there
on number six um
which says comparison of something
value of douglas's uh four different
autobiographies this is a student's
paper title
and the what comes before value is
originally written in as literary and
then
it's crossed out and the word historical
has been inserted there so that kind of
interplay of the literary
and the historical seems so um kind of
central to
rachel and laura's arguments in the
books in the book and also raised for me
what would be an interesting question
about how the archival scholar
would deal with a kind of uh with an
instance like this where the archive
presents us with some
ambiguity that we have to resolve or
some revision that we
need to make some decisions about what
its meaning was
but the other reason that i wanted to
share this picture was
um just to give you the sense of
johnson's sense that an important thing
that his students were
working toward in that classroom was the
writing of these papers
in fact johnson um typed up this list of
papers
and included it the next time he taught
this course as
in part of the course description to say
this is the kind of work that students
would be
doing in his course
so i wanted to close uh with a couple of
questions
and uh these questions come out of my
own experience as a teacher
uh come out of my own experience as a
researcher in histories of discipline
and are partly prompted by some of what
we've just seen
in the archival things we've looked at
together
first i guess a question about
discipline itself and how we value it
one way to describe the project of the
teaching archive i think and
laura and rachel can maybe respond to
this characterization is that they have
reoriented our history of the discipline
of english or the discipline of literary
studies
by bringing it within the historiography
of education
in other words they're writing a history
of teaching the writing history of
classrooms
that is its own discipline education and
the history of education
and it has its own interesting kind of
transformations in the post-1968 period
specifically a kind of critique of
a traditional liberal account of the
value or the meaning of
education public and otherwise
there was in the post-1968 period a
really kind of
um radical critique of educational
institutions this is we can associate
this with
foco's work on knowledge and power but
also major critiques by
postcolonial and indigenous scholars
were thinking about the alliance
between educational institutions and
politics and and a
kind of forms of power that they very
much saw themselves
in opposition to and so i wonder uh
what that kind of account of what a
classroom is
might do with and in conversation with
the kind of story that
uh rachel and laura are telling us in
the teaching archive
which is so much um so much a book about
reminding us or teaching us again how to
value what happens in classrooms how to
value
education and its institutions across
different kind of
social stratifications uh
along with that i wanted to raise a
question about the teaching of
writing um and the um
the josephine miles example of english
1a
really helps us to get there i think
that's a place where
the book is really thinking about the
composition classroom
because one question i did have in uh
reading the text had to do with whether
the emphasis on literary studies and
reading
how how that fits in relation to the
kind of stratification or division
between the teaching of literature and
the teaching of writing
both of which might be thought of as
very integral to the history of english
as a discipline
but which are increasingly kind of
separated out from each other and
in hierarchized ways within universities
today
in my own research and my own
writing i've sometimes made an argument
that we need to learn to see close
reading itself as a form of writing
and i realized that a kind of
a kind of critique of that implicit in
in the teaching archive might be to say
that i am doing the thing that that
laura and rachel
accuse disciplinary historians and
theorists
of doing when they say that we
overemphasize
our published writing and underemphasize
what happens
in the but classroom has often felt to
me that thinking about literary
criticism
about what's called reading as a
practice of writing
can have the other effect as well that
is it links up with
the teaching of composition it links up
with the teaching of writing
and makes those things part of a
continuous practice rather than
insisting on a division between them so
i'd really be interested to hear
and maybe i could just bring laura and
rachel and alice all back on now
and i present those to you as open
questions and
the starting points for our conversation
thank you caleb and i'm encouraging
people to
enter their intervention in the q a but
meanwhile pass the floor
to our authors for some responses and
i'll have for some responses due to that
that great uh intervention by caleb
yeah thanks caleb i mean we could spend
the last 20 minutes just on one of these
questions so maybe we'll try to touch
really briefly
on on them uh make sure we have time for
others um
but yes i mean i think we also see that
that
fukudian turn in literary studies too we
have the same debate about the history
of the novel
right and how we're gonna um i think the
thing i'd emphasize about our work is
that we are trying to value
but not glamorize or paint portraits of
like great teachers
but really just trying to think
not just but really trying to think more
about what practice
looked like and i think that those
cucudian
critiques of education have still been
real and the
disciplinary historic works that do
engage them have been really important
to us
um i mean the same thing that people
point out about foucault and its uses
is true for the sort of the the history
aggregate education turn which is that
the code is not saying you can undo that
those aspects of institutions right
um and so it's all we think part of the
history of the discipline and that's
what we're trying to get at laura would
probably have things to add to that
yeah i mean i think we when we started
working on this about 10 years ago
i think there was a sense in literary
studies particularly in the wake of
guillory's cultural capital
um and conversations around that um
that there was you know guillory's
making an argument essentially
about in the midst of the culture wars
um about the contents of reading lists
and you know
suggesting that merely adding
you know minority authors onto reading
lists in order to make them more
representative
kind of ignores the the larger function
of the school itself and in the
reproduction of
homogeneity of hierarchies
and you know that sort of left i think
that left people with a sense almost
that it didn't really matter
what they taught you know in their
classrooms and that this was you know
it was easy for people to feel that way
because that ar there already wasn't
much public conversation
beyond the culture wars around common
conversation
around classroom teaching and i think
there was a tendency to kind of have
this all or nothing fantasy about
classrooms like either
classrooms were sort of all-powerful
and reproductive or you know you could
never hope to
accomplish anything in your classroom
that would extend out into the real
world so i think when it began
we were really just looking for
something more of a middle ground of
what it actually felt like that some
you know some things failed something
succeeded
most things were that were happening
were not entirely under your control
anyways
um and to sort of begin to develop a
vocabulary around that
i think and in response to your second
question about
the connection or this kind of maybe
break between
the teaching of composition and the
teaching of literature
um i will you know you can definitely
see the formation
of that discipline and the growing split
between them
and the different labor practices um
that ensue
around the teaching of composition and
the teaching of literature
i will say the history of comp they have
done
a much better job of historicizing their
teaching
they have really excellent disciplinary
histories they have a really good sense
of the kind of communal property of
their pedagogy
and and i think you know in literary
study
the miles chapter is a really good
example of this there's just
really unrecognized genealogies of
literary study that emerge from
the teaching of writing and the teaching
of composition and i think given that so
many of us
do both you know always have done both
um
in terms of just our graduate student ta
ships and then
what a lot of people's jobs look like
nowadays um
you know we really haven't well
accounted i think for
that continual kind of cross-pollination
around those kinds of courses
and then these upper division english
courses
um if i could step in i was so moved
because
of course i took english 1a at berkeley
yeah and i have a very vivid memory of
reading lolita
in english 1a yeah yeah
and i i also thought it was incredible
the way miles had them go stand on a
street corner in berkeley
because it's the exact method of the
avant-garde french literary movement the
ulipo
i mean george perek who set himself up
on the plaza piece to observe
the totally banal you know for hours and
hours
and she sounds like an artist i mean she
she was had it was it's almost like
pre-situationism what she was having
them do
and i don't know if she was aware of
that but it's a it's a fantastic
exercise in documentary writing
that she was doing that was one comment
and my other comment is about teaching
composition versus teaching
literature the equivalent of that in the
national literatures of course is
teaching
beginning language versus teaching
the great works and so
i think those of us in the national
literatures we all started as teachers
teaching elementary grammar which is
even more of a distinction than teaching
writing and teaching
english literature and i've always
thought that we have very different
styles
because of that as teachers because we
we start out learning that what you do
is listen
so it does really change the authority
dynamic in the classroom
just in case you have it's more these
are more like comments than questions
for you but i wonder if it
evokes something for for all of you
yeah i know that's illuminating because
i hadn't i hadn't that hadn't occurred
to me but it's also true that it's kind
of almost closer to what miles is doing
the idea of teaching
teaching at the level of grammar
and language then assuming that our
students already know the structure of
the sentence the structure of a
paragraph it is more like
language learning yeah
caleb yeah that's also uh true uh
uh you would find that in the james
weldon johnson uh teaching archive as
well that his
introductory course was a language and
literature course although it's in the
english department but has a good deal
of grammar and vocabulary built into the
uh the literary reading that they're
doing
we've got a couple questions here's
one somebody who values immensely the
turn of the everyday practice of the
discipline rather than its manifesto
statements or public quarrels
but wonders how you make the bridge from
the
oral place and context specific location
of the classroom
to the public published and circulated
domain
of written criticism which has its own
overlooked everyday practices of written
style
yeah that's a good point i mean there's
really interesting recent work by
jonathan kramnik on exactly this topic
on on how the everyday the kind of real
practical continuous work of published
criticism
in literary studies focuses on like in
what he calls in-line quotation
just studying the incorporation of
the text that you're looking at into
your own language
i think yeah i mean we try to make the
when we say that we're able to see
classrooms kind of present within works
of um
criticism with the major works of
criticism um
we said that in a kind of brief form
here
but we can expand on that a little bit i
think um
even with the example of the elliott um
and you know i think one of the things
we notice is that
the sort of ethos of the classroom that
place specific oral and very communal
um scene of valuing literature
does get worked up um in in places like
the sacred wood
or in even in miles's work on poetry
rather than poems
into a kind of vision of literary
tradition that is very populous
that is populated by what eliot calls
second order minds
critics translators writers of paratext
and so there is i think a sense that
when you pivot to
the writing of criticism you're sort of
doing it
coming stepping out of the classroom
with more of a sense of how many hands
are involved
in the creation of a piece of published
writing
and in the eventual reception of it and
hopefully the longer
trajectories that it makes possible
right by making other kinds of writing
possible
so that was something in stepping for us
and moving from this classroom scene to
people's published scholarship we
started to pay attention
to these ways of thinking about literary
tradition literary value and the
practice of writing that seemed more
commun more populous and communal than
we've been
led i mean you completely deconstruct
our
mythology about the new criticism you
completely redo
our sense of the new criticism i mean
that we
i mean my generation came up with the
the sacred mission of fighting the new
criticism in all its elitists
and and close reading only assumptions
so reading about elliot and
it's just it's quite astonishing yeah i
think that is i mean i think in
critiquing the new criticism and in
other things there has been a tendency
to make it
more unified more to make it bigger than
it in fact was or more
coherent or more dominant even
so i feel like too this book kind of
comes after a wave of critique that sort
of
ended up making many things a much
bigger deal
than they perhaps were in the first
instance
another question oh sorry caleb did you
want to say something before i move to
the next question
yeah i mean i just um i wanted to pick
up on laura's phrase like what kind of
writing it makes possible
you know um because i that that um
that's sort of how i think about the
method wars in a way like
it's so obviously wrong that that um
you know that our the political economy
of our profession is in decline because
of
too much ideology critique or
or the political economy of our
profession
because we don't love literature enough
or something
like it's so obviously wrong that it
makes me want to ask the question well
like what's being enabled
by this mistake what uh
what why what are people getting from
getting it wrong in this way
and i think it is that they get to treat
the
a problem with political economy as if
it were the kind of problem that they
know how to address in their writing as
it were an intellectual problem as if it
were a misreading as if it were a
conceptual mistake
um and that could be addressed therefore
through argumentation through the kinds
of skills that they know how to have and
through the kinds of disagreements that
we know how to have with each other in
public
rather than through a work of a
different kind
which would have to do with organizing
the transformation
of institutional structures and economic
circumstances
um and in that way i mean i do think
that uh you know
um offering a new history is
is a little more continuous than totally
distinct from that particular move that
is
if we under if we see this different
history you know we a thing we can do is
write a history right
um i think we can do in our role as
scott specifically in our role as
scholars is right in history and change
their history
and maybe that history can i i hope it
will i think it is
um changing our understanding of the
value of what we do but
um it's another step to transforming
that political economy obviously
yeah we talked about this a little bit
in our conclusion but we hope i think
part of what this history does
is make the work of teaching a
more clearly right like part of all the
work
that we're doing in higher education and
not separated from like
our work which is our research that we
also like to think of and which is
labor and so we we kind of it
i i completely agree with your diagnosis
of method wars like it's we're trying to
domesticate them into something we can
solve
within the english department and that's
just clearly that's a tragic tragic
mistake
um but we do hope in some way that
there's work that you can do
in the discipline to think about labor
in a nuanced and granular way that might
help
help the working problem it's a blow to
alienation
and division it's good let me go on with
questions we've now suddenly got a lot
of really interesting questions
this one is about teaching online uh
during the pandemic but also
in general on what your work tells you
about the growth of online teaching
generally versus
face-to-face classroom especially the
growth of online teaching in community
colleges
and what do you see happening in the
classrooms and
the courses
i'm
sorry no no it's i mean
yeah i think you know
we um i think many universities were
already beginning to go online before
the pandemic particularly in in the
asynchronous mode
i did training to do that at my
university there was a lot of incentive
financial incentive for professors to
move teaching online
um and you know one thing i
noticed in the training is that you're
you're very you know they're telling you
essentially
to leave out anything remotely
resembling kind of scholarly expertise
like it's like sort of you have to
really like kind of
you know give people the the
three-minute recorded video
no longer than this and so on and it
hasn't been my experience that that's
necessarily what students want or are
capable of
you know of receiving um so i do think
that there's
we talk a fair bit and just the
conclusion to the book about
um you know some of the ways in which in
the modern research university
there is a whole industry built up now
around telling professors how to teach
right and giving them advice about
teaching um
yeah centers for teaching and learning
all over
but also um visits somebody another
interesting question on the on the chat
is
what about evaluation of teaching by
colleagues
in the course of a tenure review or a
promotion review
um how does that work
yeah i mean are we capable of
i'm just imagining an extension of this
question are we capable of evaluating
someone's teaching without understanding
this larger history
and seeing one person's classroom in the
context
of all these decisions that teachers
have made over time
right i like that idea that this can
help
that having a deeper sense of the
history could help a more
professional and contextualized
disciplinarily contextualized
evaluation of teaching it's interesting
because so
when people do look at classrooms
especially the earlier classrooms that
we've looked at in scholarly research
they tend to only look at
teaching evaluations so there is this
whole kind of interesting history
of teaching evaluations being used to
stand in for classrooms the way i think
they very much
are in 10 year decisions in which anyone
cares at all about them
it's funny there's this rumor going on
in in europe that
americans are given grades by their
students
and they're really appalled by it
sort of true
yeah i've got one i think we have time
for one more
question um did you
sense that there's some connection
between
teaching strategies and research
methods but also literary production
i mean do some people's way of teaching
actually feed right in it sounds like
it's true of elliot but
other examples of the way that teaching
inspires
literary production now i take it that
means not just critical production but
the production of literary works maybe
fiction or
yeah absolutely i think probably the
best example of this in the book is jay
saunders reading
who is teaching um you know
he's teaching at hampton in the 30s 40s
and 50s
courses like negron american literature
but also courses on the novel
he's also writing um in a couple of
different
genres that are you know realist um so
he's writing a documentary he's writing
a campus
novel um and he's sort of writing all
around
this kind of question of
realist representation you know as he's
teaching in the classroom so he's
teaching dickens thinking about how
dickinson's autobiography gets written
into some of his fiction
um at the same time that he's kind of
writing all around that
matrix as well so that was a good
example of where we really needed to
look at
the fiction and the literary production
in order to understand what he was doing
in the classroom
it's fascinating that you mentioned the
campus novel because it is a genre
that's just exploded over the last 30
years
so there is something fascinating about
the scene of teaching that appeals to
novelists
and all those campus novels are not
realist i mean some of them are just
wild it's a realist
i guess the obvious i mean the obvious
thing there is uh lecture courses that
get
basically kind of collated to become
um books often kind of introductory
books in
various fields but the question about
online teaching
uh definitely reminded me that you know
last semester i recorded my lectures
as audio lectures and never has teaching
felt more to me like writing than it did
then because because it was going to be
recorded
i found i can't do these you know i
can't sort of stand in front of the room
and vamp and look at a
picture together and interact with the
students
and because you know they could play it
back and so on i felt almost the level
of like writing for publication like
each word has to be
precise in its way and i i think there's
probably a ton of
examples of places where we could find
some
student question or student response to
a lecture or even the shape of a lecture
course that ended up changing that
person's book that was based on the
um on the lecture course that they gave
me
somebody once told me that when you
teach you just never know
what of all the stuff you say is going
to stay in the minds of your students
like some don't you remember some just
weird anecdote that some
teacher told about their dog and you've
forgotten the whole rest of the chorus
but you remember
that one anecdote absolutely
all right i'm ending on a
little light note here but i just
i want to thank you all so so much
for this conversation it was really
really fun and
and inspiring and uh thank you to
to all the participants for their
questions we'll go look on the chat
too to see your comments now that that
we're
we're done with the q a so get this book
y'all and read it
and please um we are gonna put the link
with the university of chicago press
discount code we're putting it in the
chat
thank you so much alice and thank you
thank you thanks and caleb